yes Chris was killed by an IED near to
saying gaining one of the forward
operating bases when he was on patrol it
was leading a Patrol he Chris was a
corporal in the Royal Marines what did
he tell you did he ever have a chance to
talk to you about the situation in
Helmand province at the time it was the
scene of some of the bloodiest fighting
wasn't it it was it was pretty awful it
was he did mention that there was some
social aspects to what our troops were
doing that would he felt were worthwhile
in delivering medical care and social
facilities to people who just didn't
have any facilities whatsoever but it
was also a case of trying to provide
security against insurgents who
dominated the area all around the towns
in that area and still do by the end of
it only sounds that way doesn't it
Martin the troops our troops did pull
out in large number there are still some
there in the form of the SAS fighting at
the moment how surprised are you to hear
that British troops are already I mean
it's only small numbers at the moment
but are now back on the ground there I'm
not surprised because I do follow the
reports on Afghanistan of curiosity are
sort of i think we've always been there
it's a matter of what scale it's been on
i I'm a bit confused about what it is
we're actually trying to achieve
long-term like a lot of people i believe
and I've got to say I'm disappointed on
a personal level that the thing that my
son appeared to be given his life for to
provide some sort of stability in
Afghanistan seems sort of collapsed but
I can't say I'm surprised because I
think it's been heading that way for a
while I mean obviously I think we're you
I'm not sorry master to ensure up you
that I was just good so obviously we're
not saying that your young lads died in
vain that would be a tragedy but we are
finding ourselves potentially in a
situation that he had given his life to
try to stop happening it was I think
there was some confusion about what it
was all for in it started off from a
sort of government publicity point of
view as a fight against production of
drugs that seems to not be the case at
the moment I would like our government
to actually explain what it is we are
trying to support in Afghanistan and I
would like any involvement no matter how
small it is I would like some sort of
reassurance from our government that
they're going to provide full support
for our forces in what they do during
the conflict and afterwards as in the
case of our black man who's been
persecuted for doing his job so our
government seems to be confused as to
what they're actually there for sergeant
blackman there aren't your machine
swimming yeah he was he was convicted of
murder after an incident in Helmand
province although family desperately
trying to get that reduced to
manslaughter more than a more than a
hundred other families in the same
position as you with their loved ones
having perished in Helmand I know that
you you seek solace from from Wilson the
dog who who was your son your son's dog
and do you feel that yeah it would help
at all with perhaps sending more
superiors were just looking at pictures
of him there is pretty relaxed at the
moment he was it was pretty bouncy
earlier on I think wasn't he when we
first arrived what sort of supporters he
give you and you do you think that it
would help at all to send troops more
troops back to the region again I hope
not because I got no confidence that
we're actually going to sort of have a
strategy
that will realistically achieve any sort
of stability i think there's nothing
that's really been set that convinces me
that we really know what to do about the
problem then unless we actually win over
the people who are afghan ease we can't
achieve anything by relatively small
numbers of troops and so I my interest
is in the welfare of our troops not
putting them in positions where we're
not going to fully support them
unnecessarily I think I think we've got
to sort of think about what we want
Martin its it is good to talk to you we
do appreciate you taking the time to
join us August going use this afternoon
thank you very much indeed thanks a lot